- [Instructor] Depending
on where you grow up
in the United States, you
might hear a different story
about the founding of this country.
Now, I grew up in Pennsylvania
and the story that I heard was about
the Pilgrims landing at Plymouth Rock.
They were a group of
deeply religious people,
who had been persecuted in England
and were looking for a new world,
where they could practice
their religion freely,
but many of my friends grew up in Virginia
and the story they heard
was about the founding of Jamestown,
where a group of men from England,
who were adventurers
looking for gold and glory,
landed in the New World,
hoping to make a profit.
And I think both of these
stories tells us a little bit
about the founding mythology
of the United States.
Were the original settlers here
looking for religious freedom
or were they here looking
to make a quick buck?
Well, in this video I'd
like to take some time
to explore the New England colonies,
the story of the people
who landed at Plymouth Rock
and then later, at Boston,
to begin the colony
of Massachusetts Bay and
we'll see as we go along,
just how different the settlers
in Massachusetts Bay were
from those at Jamestown
and also some of the ways
in which they were quite similar.
Now, there's no question
about who got here first.
As you can see, Jamestown
was founded in 1607,
but it wasn't too much later
that the Pilgrims landed
at Plymouth Rock in 1620,
and then they were followed
by a much larger group of Puritans,
who landed at Boston and founded
Massachusetts Bay in 1630.
So let's talk about Puritans.
So who or what was a Puritan?
This is an image of Cotton Mather,
he was a prominent Puritan minister,
fact the Mather family
will go on to be one
of the great theological
families of Massachusetts.
Puritans started in England
and their main concern
was that they believed
the Church of England,
the Anglican Church, was too
much like the Catholic Church
and this is a fairly legitimate criticism,
because in many ways, the Anglican Church
was very similar to the Catholic Church,
except that instead of
being headed by the Pope,
the Church of England was led by the king.
So Puritans hoped that they could purify
the Church of England from
its many Catholic influences.
So that's where Puritan
comes from, purify,
and by this, they meant that
there were too many rituals,
too much pomp and circumstance,
and not enough focus on the Bible itself.
So they kind of wanted to strip away
a lot of the fanciness
of the Church of England.
In the 1620s, the Puritans began to face
more persecution in England.
Now, why did the English government care
about a group of religious folks
who were not big fans of
the Church of England?
Well the answer is, that
there was no separation
of church and state and so as the king
was the head of the church,
if you're casting doubt
on the church, you are then
casting doubt on the king
and so the Puritans
did not make themselves
very popular in England and sensing
that they might be in trouble,
many Puritans began to
emigrate to the new world.
They'd seen lots of tracts about Virginia
and how one could make a new life there
and they thought that perhaps,
if they went to Virginia and
they were originally aiming
to go to Virginia, they ended up landing
a bit north of there, that
they could set an example
of what a righteous church
and a righteous society
would look like, because
they believed that the church
and the society of England
were becoming much too corrupt,
much too divorced from the
principles of the Bible.
So in 1620, one group of Puritans
set out for the new world
and landed at Plymouth Rock
and we call them the Pilgrims,
and then in 1630, a second group set out
and they were just Puritans more broadly.
And over the course of the 1630s,
about 14,000 Puritans
emigrated from England
to New England, Massachusetts Bay,
in what's called the great migration.
So what was the difference
between these two groups,
The Pilgrims and the Puritans?
Well, the Pilgrims who arrived in 1620,
they were separatists and what that means
is that they thought that
the Church of England
was so corrupt that
there was just no chance
that they were going
to be able to save it.
So they wanted to separate
from that church altogether
and live a completely
separate life at Plymouth.
They had a pretty small settlement,
about a hundred people
crossed over on the Mayflower,
the ship that brought
them to the New World,
but the group that came over in 1630,
the Puritans, they did
not want to separate
from the Church of England altogether.
They wanted to purify it and they hoped
that by setting an example
of a righteous society,
they would actually convince
people back in England
to adopt their ways, invite them back,
and that all of England could
become like New England.
This man here is John Winthrop
and he was a lawyer who became
a leader of the Puritans,
he was elected governor pretty
much for his entire life
and he wrote that he
wanted Massachusetts Bay
to be like a city upon a hill
and be a kind of a beacon of light,
showing the world what a
good society could be like.
Now, obviously the New England Puritans
did not get their way,
they were not invited back
to England to become the
model of English society,
but they did become the model of society
in Massachusetts Bay and
New England, more generally,
and I think a strong influence
on American culture, writ large.
So how did life in New England
compare to life in Virginia?
Well, a lot depended on
the different environment
of the colony and the reasons
that migrants came to New England.
Because the environment of New England
was colder, the land was rockier,
it was both a healthier place to live,
because tropical diseases
couldn't flourish there
the way that they could in
the marshy areas of Virginia
and it was also the unsuitable place
for large-scale plantation agriculture.
So they couldn't grow the kinds of crops
that Virginia grew, like tobacco
or even sugar in the West Indies.
So that meant that in New England,
most of the industry was
either family farming
and fishing and also some trading,
since they were on the coast.
And because most Puritans
came over to help build
this city upon a hill,
they came in family units,
not as single men, like in Virginia,
so there was a much more
even ratio of men to women.
The families that came over
tended to be well-off enough
to pay their own passage
across the Atlantic,
tended to be kind of
middle-class, artisan types
and so New England didn't
have the kind of influx
of indentured servants that Virginia had,
nor did it have an influx
of enslaved Africans
as laborers, because most New Englanders
were farmers and they were small farmers,
so they relied on their
own family as labor.
So a major consequence
of these motivations
for emigrating and this environment,
was that New England society
was relatively egalitarian.
There were very few
very wealthy landowners,
like there were in Virginia,
and very few people who were
completely at the bottom,
like servants and enslaved people.
People who lived in Virginia
had a life expectancy
of up to 70 years, which
was one of the highest
life expectancies in
the world at this time
and because reading the Bible so important
to the Puritans, New England also had one
of the highest rates of literacy
in the world at this time,
but for all of these positives,
there were plenty of reasons
why living in New England
wasn't so much fun.
Most of them related to the strictness
of the Congregational Church.
Puritans canceled Christmas,
that they thought was too
much of a pagan ritual
and though you would think
that their own experience
of religious intolerance in England
would have led them to be more tolerant
to dissidents, that was not the case.
Anyone who disagreed
with a Puritan theology
or leadership, was given the option
to go somewhere else or be executed.
For example, Roger
Williams, who questioned
the Puritans' actions
toward Native Americans
was expelled from
Massachusetts Bay in 1636
and he went on to found
the colony of Rhode Island,
where religious dissenters
could find a place of refuge
from Massachusetts Bay, just as the people
of Massachusetts Bay had
found refuge from England.
One of these was a woman
named Anne Hutchinson,
who in 1637, was expelled
from Massachusetts Bay
for daring to be a woman
who preached the Bible.
So in this video, I've
explored some of the background
to Puritans and Pilgrims and aspects
of New England society and religion.
In the next video, we'll
continue our exploration
of New England's life through its politics
and policies toward Native Americans.